[Music]
[Music]
louder with crowder is brought to you in
part by
dot com you'll look better but more
importantly
you'll feel better unless you have kobit
then you'll probably die
dot com
[Music]
um
hmm that's what we call a that's a late
slurp
is it it's a late slurp because we're
running late today because uh the texas
power grid sucks
might want to think twice about
secession
no i mean i think there are a bunch of
coal plants too in texas that we can't
use
from some obama area we went to you know
we went to wind and solar
and i don't know if you know this hasn't
you felt a lot of wind in texas lately
nothing i don't know no not enough
it's not known for its winding
topography
very flat though so uh we are a little
late but it's a good thing because we'll
be able to talk about boudin
already had my booty moment uh biden and
putin which is fun they're meeting right
now and actually uh wolf blitzer is
talking about what he's not allowed to
broadcast on cnn right now
uh and uh i don't have a monitor working
so as sound guy tim if uh if do you
think you can step down you want to get
this going yeah get jump down there
um i won't do anything too tricky for
you with the sound uh by the way
cultural appropriation month i just want
to tell you this uh thursday
tomorrow greece oh yeah is what we're
doing so we're talking about putin and
biden
we're talking about the crime spree i
don't know if you know this now but if
you thought you had to pay for things
at uh like walgreens you don't oh
they're doing a sale huh yeah
no it's flash shoes oh no no yeah i mean
it's a it's crime sale
ah yeah yeah five finger discount boco
bocco and then we'll be talking about
charles barkley which is fun for those
big old women in san antone
all right gerald a how are you sir i'm
well how are you i'm okay
now that we're on air now that we're on
air we apologize but not really you know
those are your faults for those of you
who aren't mug club uh members you get
your money
yeah sometimes it's a lot something yeah
steal anything at uh cbs or right now
i'm working on it dude i'm i'm
working i gotta wait till i get off work
he's more of a dwayne reed guy
and uh dave you're uh how are you doing
dave landon i'm all right i'm
all right what's wrong i just put an eye
drops
ahoy everybody and you have a new show
in waterford this week and they add a
show because it was sold out and i have
another show they added a show we're not
going to do a uh late night
uh or at 9 00 p.m which is late to many
people
yeah uh the early one seven uh this
saturday uh one night stands in
waterford that's a horrible name you're
doing
two yeah at one night stand two shows at
one night stands
end for two days yeah very it's hardly a
one-night stand no that business should
be shut down in principle
well yeah they named it like hey we're
going to set out the name of our club
with limitations immediately we want the
ceiling to be as low as humanly possible
hey what if we have a popular comment
it's one one night just one
big big room though okay so it'll be a
lot of fun
dave is great okay so today i used to
have a three night one night stand yes
three night one night stan that's about
uh that's about what putin is doing with
our
former vice president right now no i
think he's about it's nap time i bring
you to where they charge you by the
hour yeah you like it but
you take it your son is there already
yes
oh wow what by the way you have great
looking family i met your niece
oh fine i think
i faked bringing hunter room service he
keep the rope for himself he never
shared the rope with the knees
nice set on your knees so look
i want to be really clear about this
peep i am not rooting for putin at all
people are saying this no
i cannot stand putin i think that putin
is a killer
oh yeah um yeah kgb yeah i want to be
really clear about this i don't think
they're murderers and i
how dare you and i uh i i hate that we
are in a position of of weakness right
you know with
with joe biden and and president putin
so i wish that we had a stronger
president and i know people have their
criticisms ready for donald trump but
we'll get to that so he's a strong
president today face-to-face meeting uh
secretary of state anthony blinken said
the meetings will focus on ransomware
cyber attacks like the colonial pipeline
and uh they will oh they won't be
holding a joint press conference
afterwards they'll be doing
separate uh press conferences and look
this is one of those things they often
do on cable news and it's useless
uh the body language experts yeah but in
this case i do
i did think it was interesting i just
want you to compare donald trump's
meeting
with putin versus former vice president
joe biden's meeting with putin just the
initial body language here you go
already this morning our first look at
the first greeting between president
trump and president putin
posted online by the german government a
handshake and pat on the back
the quick interaction
listen to this
okay that shake his hand in just a
second when i'm ready
obviously that will continue but we look
forward to a lot of very positive
things happening for russia for the
united states
and for everybody concerned and it's an
honor to be with you
thank you
[Applause]
for any agreements or any potential for
agreement it's likely that the
presidents
would task some of their aides their
advisors to try to pursue it
going forward but just as we get started
on this data we call
in the business of pools
for the very beginning across his legs
so we get that visual we get that
picture
then the cameras are out and the
business begins we're going to have our
president joe
[Laughter]
don't interrupt me this is not the view
for years and years and years and
anthony blinken who has been
all right that's enough i made my flex
one inch bigger
yes little things let me
now the thing is just so people know too
donald trump has talked about body
language at all i'm sort of asserting uh
asserting an authoritative position yeah
they say you're going to shake his hand
he says
in a second in computers wait a second
and he's also doing this pointing
right like he's a child like look that's
the uh advocate like he's in a waiting
room at a
pediatrician that's the if you take that
thing along the metal wire it goes to
the end
that's a coloring book that's a map
that's highlights for children yeah you
know he is the guy
but they're defecting control now do you
think that and this is one thing too
look i hate that donald trump
complimented putin
i absolutely do but this is important to
note
donald trump uh did compliment uh for
example kim jong-un at one point yeah
did compliment putin but
he negotiated from a position of power
which matters for example people made a
big deal that donald trump crossed over
to the north korean border first person
first president
to do it guess what his deal was
denuclearized or nothing
yeah and they didn't and he left with
nothing yeah and then he crapped all
over kim jong-un
so donald trump was complimentary would
prefer it be neutral but from a position
of power
here is my concern former vice president
joe biden
is insulting calling putin a killer
before he walks it back
from a position of weakness that's the
worst thing you could
it's like talking trash to a bully who
knows that he can kick your ass
now why do i say that because under
obama's watch despite what people want
to talk about russian cyber meddling
because of ten thousand dollars of
facebook ads
under uh former vice president biden's
watch with barack obama at the helm as
opposed to kamala harris
invaded ukraine illegally annexed crimea
joined the syrian war in support of the
syrian president uh
al-assad kind of a big kind of big ones
yeah absolutely uh hitler when he
started the second world war essentially
took the sudetenland away and the world
did nothing putin did the exact same
thing so if you want to compare
donald trump to a tyrant look at putin
that's an actual tyrant he takes parts
of other countries
whenever he wants he jails dissidents he
kills his own citizens
and we've sent a guy over there who can
barely walk up a flight of stairs
well not only that but he did it less as
far as internationally
acted up less putin under donald trump's
watch and you know what else that's true
everyone said donald trump is is caving
to putin by pissing off our nato allies
no he said they needed to pay their fair
share and guess what for the first time
in two decades
they did yeah exactly they started
paying more than point five percent
well it's my understanding he's a bigot
ah yeah
yeah i i watched the coverage this
morning and cnn's like
it'll be nice to get russian and u.s
relations they won't be good but they'll
be predictable and i'm like predictably
weak is not good it was okay that putin
didn't
know what donald trump was going to do
it kept him in check a little bit right
he was like what wait
why you juke me what you do exactly this
guy he's not president he's shock and
jive
you i don't like you but i respect you
where's biden he's like you call me
killer come over here sit on my lap
better yet bring your knees
he comes so he tries to hand me the new
codes and i reach and he just lifts it
up so high i can't get it oh
yes he pranks me you know what i do to
former vice president's bite i go hey
i'm going to da and i don't even have
any hair he's [ __ ]
yes i stab you with poison umbrella and
i do no handshake
i mean this is a genuine question to you
guys out there what do you
who do you think is going to be more
firm with putin do you think that it was
donald trump do you think joe biden do
you think it's going to improve our
relationship here's the thing
i don't like putin i want to call him
out as the horrible killer that he is
he's one of the world's wealthiest men
through ill-gotten gain but i also don't
want to go to war
with russia i don't want to have another
cold war and i certainly don't want to
i certainly don't want to get into any
kind of conflict with like you said a
man who still has to use the bunny
method for his laces
i don't even want to get a double knot i
don't even want to get a shave in russia
would you trust that no you'd be like
this thing is getting dragged across my
throat by the end of it
it comes with complementary hip a yes
enjoy
hipaa that's what we call it right it's
like filter
so um all right here's something else
that i want to talk while we're going
let's go across the pond
back to here oh here because america
first
today second because we talked about
russia first um
this is i need to warn you if you have
children here i want to i want to sort
of look at the
the macro a little bit there's been a
lot of crimes that people have not
covered for example uh
well there was one with it was there was
another one that we don't even have in
the show today was it alabama or
louisiana or was racially motivated
where they go oh yeah we shot uh
i think it was a black guy that was of
course after white guys it was racially
motivated in that case but
that's why you didn't hear about it yeah
um and we are seeing more crime we're
seeing
crime spike across the country but i
think what people don't
what people are missing here is we've
had abs
things ebb and flow yeah right with
crime right but there is a
notable spike here and there's a notable
pattern of behavior
and it really is right now we have a
culture where there's a complete lack of
accountability
where criminals feel that they can
commit what we're once
relatively serious crimes without any
consequences
compared to you know russia where you're
in a punk band and you never see the
light of day again
yeah well they were basically told that
they can do these things yes
yes so uh before we get to walgreens
which everyone was talking about this
happened uh
monday but i don't think the footage was
really out there until yesterday
um i'm warning you guys this this man uh
gets shot a security guard but he lives
you don't see him get shot in the video
but you do see the lead up
so i still if you have children around i
wouldn't have them watch this uh
lennox mall in atlanta i guess used to
be one of the the better malls
shot in the chest uh point blank
so the story says they were demanding
his apple store card
i think and that is
a rotund lady
with the firearm according to police
report
[Music]
for people listening it's very clear the
security guard does
not want to get violent he's trying to
avoid confrontation two people cornering
him
with a firearm
and finally you don't see it but
yeah that's what happens uh the man no
he lived not good he's still alive from
what i understand
hey can i can i say at this point can i
say
uh can i say overweight hood rat [ __ ]
when she shoots someone with a gun who
is innocently trying to be non-violent
can i call that woman a [ __ ] i just
want to make sure that's not a violation
of youtube guidelines
calling someone hey can we say that that
woman can't
at least can i say she's acting [ __ ]
but that's
blowing a hole through a man's chest
cavity yeah who didn't deserve
any of it by the way and this is not an
isolated incident
um this happened by the way atlanta zone
two
so i looked up some police stats from
there uh murders have increased 17
since last year geez shootings 26 but
here's the kicker
they they increased from 2019 to 2020
133
murders and shootings 164
so total you're looking at about 150
and uh one 80 something respectively
since the riots have started yeah that's
what i was about to say 2020 was
horrible for most places i can't believe
they are out doing that now
really i no i can't because i thought
2020 would be the worst oh my gosh it's
like a pinball machine they're trying to
hit the high score i know
well it's almost like they got away with
stuff for so long they just kept doing
it because it actually has
nothing to do with the cause yeah that's
logical stop it
and it's almost as though there are no
consequences yeah hey
weird when you take away consequences
from shitty people
you know what i see there though two
things that might two things that might
solve that problem actually what maybe
three
we need it first obviously fix systemic
discrimination
yeah two more gun control and three
send in a social worker you want to send
in people who can do less
than the guy who was just shot he's a
security guard
they shot paul blart i assume he has
some kind of a baton
that's what happened there you go now
you know what happens if you send in
if you send in social workers who are
less capable in the realm of physical
violence you ever met one well do they
have a clipboard
yes yeah i'm in full support well they
talk sternly to the individual yeah i am
also in full support yeah
send them in no i just would like to see
i think it's an important test
yes yeah we'll see if this works i mean
it's only fair
if you have a social studies degree
we'll send you to atlanta's own too it
just makes common sense
yeah by the way i was a little blown
away by the the people recording it
and they how long it took them to come
to the acknowledgement that we need to
call the police they're like
well i think we uh i think we need the
call notice that we didn't show that yet
another clip no yeah by the way if
you're filming
someone aiming a gun at somebody yeah
and you have 45 seconds before they
you're you've lived an asshole's life
yeah yeah there's cameras around and you
could switch that camera you got right
into the 911
phone yeah exactly direct connection to
the phone
buddy they're like no no wait wait till
someone gets hurt right it actually
started as a phone
my very first cell phone my parents said
only use this to call us in an emergency
after you've called 9-1-1 it's crazy
otherwise you're going to get a second
summer job and pay the roaming fees
they weren't like do me a favor take 400
pictures of yourself you narcissist
yes send pictures of your tits to your
you know whoever doesn't have to be your
boyfriend no we're progressing somebody
arrest us
we let you drink in the house um and
this goes to what happened yesterday
which has gone viral
uh two well so that's an extreme example
yeah and this is another example
um of well people don't know this
anything under 950
in san francisco that you steal is no
longer uh basically they can't do it oh
i'll be back right
yeah are you serious yes i think you
have the number here it's uh it's
anything under 950
is petty theft oh my gosh yes nobody
will stop you
and so there are actually banks there
are actually many incidents of people
stealing precisely 949
of course what if you like leave and
then come back in and get another 950 is
it like
how about you do that math and become an
accountant
i just i would go from bank to bank i
need to withdraw
904 all right do you have an account sir
no but i'm told this is okay
and i want to do it in pennies and if
you have the world's largest sock
dude so these people
shut uh the that guy those that security
guard was shot by two people
and then here two two wall green
security guards in san francisco
just watch as a man with a bicycle
inside of walgreens
yeah take stuff so you think you think
someone comes in
with sticky hands on a bicycle you might
say oh something's going on here
might be on alert better let them finish
nothing crossed their mind as you can
hear by the conversation
here you go san francisco
not the head she's getting cardio guy in
the man bun
he's stealing hair color the weakest
thing ever
stop it look he's not even in a rush
with the automatic door
no he's oh wait unbelievable i've i've
been i've been
more uh frustrated you know more rushed
there's more of a sense of urgency when
i get an angry text from my pregnant
wife yeah
stupid walgreens door this guy's just
like wait for it it'll open the most
ironic thing is he brought his bike in
because he's afraid someone might steal
it
yeah he can just leave it outside just
walks out it's just a hanging lock
you animals there's a lot of crime
around here
is there no honor in this town
doesn't pay to take chances um but he
brought his own trash bag that was nice
oh but he was this is one thing he was
he was stealing the set i saw him
stealing you know
uh milk yeah like wrapping medications
no
definitely it wasn't razor bump lotion
hey that's that's necessity yeah i know
i got the curly hair i got to do it
otherwise you get those ingrown hairs
one time i pulled one out it was like
jafar's beard
and this is this is something to this
you know new jersey was just voted uh or
it was just named best state to live in
oh my god i thought the headlines write
themselves
but think about this for a second this
is what happens in new jersey
in new jersey you can actually be sued
by someone who breaks into your house
because new jersey has castle doctrine
no no you also have a duty to retreat
in other words unless you can prove that
there was no there was no back door
yeah if you trip a guy in your house you
could be sued
we are now in an environment like in san
francisco
where criminals are encouraged and law
abiding citizens
are discouraged from taking part in
society they're fearful
yeah they are afraid and uh this is of
course true you see that i was surprised
that i don't know i you know twitter
obviously has their thumb on the button
you could at least try and make the left
look good because when walgreens was
trending
immediately left us rushed to the
defense of these people so let me read
you some of these
these these criminal pray victim shaming
is a thing oh yeah
perpetrator praising is a thing yes
definitely
so one guy wrote organized crime equals
one dude on a bicycle
shoplifting from walgreens the real
organized crime preventing people from
getting their medicine as the
pharmaceutical industry
yeah i'm sure he was picking up his
ivermectin
the real organized crime would have
tuned that guy upside
this is high street give me all [ __ ]
yeah exactly
i just i just can't imagine you know
when i was a kid and i was afraid of
like oh
i had my grandfather's breast knuckles
and they were technically illegal
this didn't even cross their mind i when
you know when you're kids like oh i got
black cats yeah i'm not supposed to have
them because i'm not 18.
they're like yeah i know what that feels
like i ripped off a pack of razors and
18 bags of nicotine gum and didn't pay a
dime
like we live two very different lives i
would still see these i'm not gonna lie
i was that kid and tapes
and i felt bad years later and i swear
to god i would have gone back but
they're out of business
maybe it was because of all the
shoplifting tapes yeah i think it was
that and technology changed
but i would have gone i went back to
places where i dined and dash because i
felt really bad
found the waitress and left giant hips
really
better than yours later i did yeah yep
where are you
young and stupid you don't realize
that's a yeah
can you this is the kamala defense right
well i know he's shoplifting from
walgreens but big farm i'm like the two
aren't connected yeah he's not
he's not behind the farm by the way by
the way you guys are walking billboards
for big pharma yeah
okay two companies and i'm not saying
that i'm not
saying anything any vaccine at all no
but i'm saying you guys have no problem
asking for mandates and passports
with really only three companies two
that have a duopoly in the united states
with moderna and pfizer i never want to
hear from you or stephen
stephen colbert did a let's all go to
the lobby with vaccinations by
pharmaceutical name never again can you
lecture me about big pharma i don't care
about your kashtanga root or what you're
doing with your
ayurvedic medicine no no no when
when push came to shove you guys became
quizlings for two pharmaceutical
companies
it's done it's over you're lacking
go home now these are other tweets
justifying it
regarding the walgreens ceo getting a 25
million dollar bonus
if you're concerned about looting i've
got some news for you
oh well there's a hot take and then of
course
residents here resident pile of garbage
tarik nasheed tweeted
this walgreens situation is one of those
see what happens when we don't let the
police do their job and kill those n
words propaganda stories
well i believe you're paraphrasing
because i wouldn't use that type of
racist language but the general
sentiment
correct yes so that's not what happened
he left on a bike with a trash bag
strolled away having a cop handcuff him
is not this like
tell me the story where somebody has
been shoplifting and his behavior was
like officers i'm sorry i'll drop the
goods and was shot
and killed right as far as i'm concerned
that
man bunned uh guy in the bomber jacket
that looks like he was one of the
the guards in the santa claus when the
elves tied him up with tinsel
that guy should have clotheslined this
guy in the bicycle like doing the clown
and a [ __ ] was running out before
him that's how brutal it should have
been what's his name gingerly touched
his bag as yeah
just kept his phone in his pocket for
crying out loud
throw that left with everything you've
got he's riding into it it's a free
knockout
how in the what does he do like a
genuine question now if you're
not guard at a store that doesn't do
anything like you're just getting free
money to stand there and watch a show
it's actually it's worse than that
because it used to be we're helpless
right because
you don't carry firearms because you
don't you're you you don't believe
that there is such a thing as righteous
violence in the case of someone
committing a crime or even an assault
but they're further on down the trail
where they're afraid if they call 9-1-1
oh is that enforcing systemic i don't
know i don't know
how about 4-1-1 we'll just get some
information 4-1-1
what should i do but you're going to
lose your business if you don't stop
people from coming in and stealing
everything yeah
exactly well this is something that's
also interesting uh arrests in san
francisco have gone way down despite
larceny going up so see that number
there were years where over 60 percent
yeah of those
those thefts went you know either
arrested prosecutor charged down this
was it 17
well crime is going down stephen they're
not prosecuting yeah exactly
so the numbers are good yeah it's a good
thing so they've already closed 17
walgreens in san francisco
some people say it's due to theft some
people say well no you can't argue it's
due to theft because they've closed a
ton of stores in new york too
i understand your point there but i
would argue they closed in new york also
due to theft
yes dwayne reads there that we're
shutting down left and right when i was
living there
right it was theft yeah i don't even
know i don't even know why they bother
putting prices on the 32-ounce beer cans
at dwayne rooney
it's like it should just be buy one it's
just be
just take one take one take two i was at
dwayne reed many times
i was like i should just leave yeah
you're all doing it i don't want to wait
in line
and by the way the only one i have no
doubt no doubt for a second
that if i went up to a walgreens in san
francisco and said okay i'll take the
nicotine gum give me a i don't know some
lighter fluid give me a
home cover test and i tried to walk out
they would beat
my large white ass without thinking
twice because no one's going to be
scared about beating me up
we should test this think about it yeah
there's no risk of them being accused of
nothing not at all this is the issue
right now as people are afraid they
don't want to be in the nightly news
and lose their entire livelihood let's
let's be honest about what it is
what if you what if you wore like a blm
shirt or something does this give me a
cover
no no you could be an ally it doesn't
matter if i'm an ally
they'll beat my sorry allied ass they
would rather just
you not be on the nightly news and just
lose their entire livelihood anyway to
the theft
it's like it's a slow burn dave and i
love how people separate i don't know if
if walgreens i believe in certain states
it's uh there are franchises because of
different pharmaceutical laws but
in general it's corporate but look let's
not act like walgreens is the only place
that's been affected by this when people
say oh these giant ceos
do you know what a franchise is yeah do
you know that a franchise allows mom and
pop
shops to actually start up businesses
without all of the overhead yeah you
know when you go to when you go to
whatever it could be a chili's or
buffalo wild wings
half of these places are franchises
they're small business owners who just
didn't
didn't have didn't have the capital to
start something on their own
you are hurting them yeah people have
this idea that you own a turnkey
business and you're a
multi-multi-multi-millionaire right
some people own three or four different
ones and maybe make 15 grand a year
eventually off of each one
right imagine somebody who franchised
the subway two days before
jared got arrested they were like
finally
our dream yeah i'm sorry our
spokesperson did uh what he's just
bringing out the new
footlong back into the day yeah
no no you remember we coming because
these used to be jared's pants
oh boy he could fit a kid in there i had
a 401k before this
why i i just quit my job for this
sandwich
well you guys remember this started with
walmart whenever they locked up certain
products that were high theft products
they were accused of being racist
yes and now that i mean and they went
and took it away and they said okay i
guess we can i guess we have to allow
theft now i guess theft is now a social
it's a human right no it's not i guess
they are allowing theft in san francisco
950 but here's the thing 950 you say
okay fool me once another 950 dollars
all right wait hold on a second me think
someone should keep an eye on the people
coming in on bicycles
950 345 it adds up people don't
understand you can lose thousands of
dollars a day and they do and they're
closing down stores can you attribute it
only to theft no but i'm pretty sure it
factors into the equation nine thousand
dollars a day
put that in like what if my work day is
just walking from store to store
stealing as much as i'd make five ten
grand a week oh my god awesome
that's wearing a mask it's just
trick-or-treating yeah you know 500
a year 50 weeks i can take two weeks off
for christmas i'm in the wrong line of
work
you can steal a mask from there during
halloween yeah
no then they would cut your ass if you
walked in that's true like
even we have limits their standards step
over the human poop
needles come and steal 950 but if you
don't have a mask speak into the
microphone sister
i love how though they lock up high
theft items they're like oh yeah we
you know people are stealing a lot of
them well that's racist all right then
they unlock it's like oh did that fix it
well no no they just kept they stealed
it again
i don't know they're gone now but at
least we're not racist so that's good
but at least we were way off on that
stop breaking the law
oh go to the back room order more argon
oil or argon oil
i don't even care if you steal from a
walmart
at least we know it won't be ar-15 ammo
oh no these giant corporations that have
taken over everything and i used to not
be that kind of the corporations but now
that
basically the liberal agenda is rude for
the corporations yeah have at it
they all support these things yeah no
you love it
and it really has fundamentally changed
uh it really has fundamentally changed
the fabric of our country here and we've
even talked about this this
is just the one that you see but it's
been going on for the last several weeks
you know you guys remember they
cancelled cops
yeah yeah for obvious reasons yeah the
show yeah but there is the reiteration
uh
now that's been playing for weeks no
cops and uh there were quite a few
instances
of what we're discussing in last week's
episode
tonight on no cops boss
[Music]
stay tuned
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah he's like i don't know can i get
like a a review on one of these
this is locked i need to i need to get
into everything i'm not
heartless just most of it she brought a
rollerboard
suitcase i know right and then he's he's
gonna be fair she stole the samsonite
from kohl's that's true yeah
you gotta hit kohl's before he goes
stealing stuff elsewhere he goes oh oh
so now i gotta take your phone you made
me do it
come on now and it's the same leg like i
don't know should i call 9-1-1 first
no okay all right let's see
oh you record i'm forced to take your
phone now i'm sorry i didn't want to
steal it
i'm a samsung guy i guess i'll be
phoning the bus um
so yeah you and you know what i actually
want to hear from you guys up there have
you
seen more theft if you guys live
particularly people who live in major
cities because we get a lot of uh we get
a lot of mail about it but just in the
comments section i'd be interested to
see
this is totally anecdotal right because
we do have the statistics here but
you know let me know what your
experience has been um and this brings
us to remember the austin shooter
yesterday yeah and look obviously
because it's been it's just the
compression has been
so severe uh if it seems like we're
making light of this
we're not i just you know when you're
when your country is potentially going
to hell in a hand basket
you uh you have to laugh otherwise you
might defend your property
and that's racist it's a problem and a
hand basket pretty good for shoplifting
yes it is doesn't uh doesn't uh doesn't
compete with a rolling samsonite
but still so much storage space
samsonite is greater than trash bag
at that point just commit just steal the
shopping cart
exactly pull the bubbles
as long as it's under 949 um so the
austin shooter we covered yesterday for
people who don't remember right npr
uh identified this is just the kind of
bias that people may not know is taking
place and i wanted to reiterate it
because some people missed this npr
was once thought of as unbiased news
they named the race of the assailant
of the victim in several instances but
then never as it related to the
austin mass shooting which is usually
right arrays on deck for the media the
mass shooting
it's like catnip for dishonest reporters
but this is how they covered it
a woman was killed in minneapolis last
night after a man drove his vehicle at
high speed
into a crowd of demonstrators as matt
sepik of minnesota public radio reports
protesters detained the alleged attacker
until police arrived
the demonstrators blocked lake street in
the city's uptown area to protest the
killing of winston smith
sheriff's deputies on a u.s marshals
service task force fatally shot the 32
year old black man june 3rd while trying
to arrest him
on a firearms warrant local activist dj
hooker says a driver accelerated through
barricades and hit several parked cars
one of which struck and killed a woman
sitting on the curb
a car came at us going like 70 or 80
miles an hour
i just have to show this to you guys
longer so you know it's not edited
at all and it hit the car video that
hooker took at the scene shows
protesters detaining the apparent driver
a white man and handing him over to
police for npr news
i'm matt sepik in minneapolis you're
listening to npr news from washington
now the very next story officials in
austin texas say a man has died of his
injuries following a mass shooting
downtown early saturday morning no race
left more than a dozen people injured at
least one suspect has been arrested
austin police say they think the
shooting began as a dispute between two
parties
the incident occurred along austin's
sixth street a popular nightlife
destination
a winning bidder is set to join jeff
bush now we're on to the next story
i mean it's almost pattern disruption
you're like okay here oh i'm black man
okay okay
i don't know okay a white man and then
wait what
nothing well do they not know stephen do
they not well look and this is just this
is the issue
with people saying why are you
responding to it because the left
obviously listen when you when you
understand critical race theory when you
understand identity politics they
absolutely are dividing our country more
than we've ever seen and they are
creating i've said this for a long time
i said this
before these things started before these
current riots started
i said it before the 2016 election i was
really worried that you were going to
create
more racists i just didn't know that we
would actually have
violent anti-white racism so quickly
as an epidemic yeah and i hate i hate to
say this
i hate especially someone who goes to a
mixed church
you're going to have the backlash and
you're going to have an epidemic
of white people saying all right well
look if you're going to vilify me and
steal our stuff
and and cons there's no accountability
except for me being
the evil villain i'm taught that in
school guess what
they're going to resent people of other
races
this is what worries me you can't
browbeat a kid
right you can't browbeat a generation of
of
young white straight males particularly
for stuff they didn't do
stuff that existed generationally ago
that we all agree horrible
slavery of course glad we had the civil
war
understand it but you can't browbeat a
kid and say
i'm stealing your stuff why because
you're white okay i'm beating you up why
because you're white i'm shoot i'm
shooting up your mouse why because
you're white until he goes oh
it's a race thing and then you end up
with a
you end up with a race war stop it
turn it back turn it back guys i i'm
hoping it's not too late i said this in
2015.
but here we are i didn't know that it
would turn on so quickly so the austin
american statesman
they also refused to provide a
description to avoid perpetuating
stereotypes they said which by the way
is in and of itself kind of racist
yeah a little bit you're assuming stuff
well yeah
yeah especially when you understand they
release the mug shot here you go yep
there you go well
ah oh so it's a lead singer of counting
crows
yes he's white though and by the way hit
the notification bell if you're
subscribed because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot right now
uh since we are live a little bit later
it looks like there are there's going to
be
individual press conferences from biden
and putin so if that comes up we'll
cover it here live
also just wanted to let you know austin
was saying that cnn was saying they had
two sessions
and most people were expecting for the
summit to go about five hours yeah
yeah but the white house said that it
was only one session
and the meeting only went about two and
a half hours yeah well then he [ __ ]
himself well yeah he
he needed stamina for that here's the
thing also keep in mind
if i'm not mistaken uh former vice
president joe biden
cleared the day yesterday after you know
he mispronounced i believe it was libya
in syria he confused the two three times
right he had a really really rough
monday yeah he cleared the deck
yesterday to recoup
i think it's pretty clear at this point
look no one can obviously medically
diagnose the former vice president and
say
dementia or alzheimer's and i think it's
irresponsible for people to say that
definitely i agree yeah
but i think we can all at the very least
say low energy
he's maybe not at the top of his game
right now i wanted to really quickly go
back to what you just said the top of
women's doubles
you said that it creates this backlash
in in kind of the white community we're
made the
the i guess the the perpetrator of all
things wrong right right it does the
opposite on the other side it actually
encourages
black people to think the only reason
that you're being held down right now in
society is because of systemic racism
because of white people so
it puts this group as the victim all the
time white people now are being
victimized by crime and get backlash and
it tells this group it's okay to do it
you're telling both sides to go fight
each other that's all you're doing fake
victim culture
creates real victims that's the issue
yeah 100 the problem
with all of it too is you are saying the
color except for the one group and you
are hiding the stuff it's
oh it's a stereotype if we say that it's
him yeah those type
those type of shootings in particular
aren't usually a black guy that's why
they didn't say his name
because you would automatically think it
was a white guy right well actually
statistically mass shootings are four or
more and yes
most i realized that that statistic is
very much so
right but when you think of somebody who
like shoots up in office
you're not thinking black guy that's
just the reality it's true and they're
very very few and far between as far as
gun crime statistics this is something
that we need to talk about
um and by the way common argument for
what people have been presenting why the
police didn't identify
the suspect was because he's a minor oh
how fast before we knew kyle
rittenhouse's name
and how long before we knew that he shot
a serial
convicted pedophile i'm sorry
seventeen's a minor
dave's got some sorrows i'm not to
hunter no
no of course not by the way what what's
more like
no is a minor it's all fair game
ah ah former vp you'll know
i have to i'm concerned about videotape
yeah what's the uh
don't do that what's what's the
stereotype they were trying to avoid uh
because he was a minor
uh because they said well it was a
stereotype that they don't remember
scallions i i'm just curious have you
seen men as the society
yes it's always it's always the young
people and my dog was 17 though
and this is the issue too when we're
talking about fake victim culture
creating real victims
this really does go from it happens from
the top down so let's take
up austin mayer for example who by the
way
by the way was talking to joe rogan yeah
i remember not long ago and saying he
needed to
figure out how to address the homeless
problem so we asked cities like san
francisco and seattle oh what
what what trying to create more what
i wanted to learn how to not get aid so
i resuscitated the corpse of freddie
mercury
i just uh san francisco and seattle
i know that i know that you couldn't be
mayor of a major city
i think we all know freddie mercury was
a blood transfusion yes yes yeah yeah
you sat on the wrong toilet seat got to
put down those papers and by sat in the
wrong toilet seat i mean uh it was
george michael sitting on the toilet
uh the mayor of austin and this msnbc
interviewer stephanie rule
rule uh blamed texas gun laws
for the lack of police presence uh over
there in uh in austin wait there's
another clip before this isn't there
um what's the next clip clip four
all right let's roll this clip four we
have seen mass shootings across the
country but really
across the state of texas and now there
are barely
any gun control laws in your city in
your state
are your police now changing the way
they respond do they need to
you know what what our state legislature
what our state just did with respect to
to allowing uh anyone to to carry a
firearm without
uh registration is just absolutely just
me one thing is clear
greater access to firearms doesn't equal
greater safety
police certainly don't want this more
guns on this
make it harder for the police to do
their job and washington isn't helping
right uh keep in mind that uh
one of the shooters he was 17 he
couldn't legally own a fire yeah yeah
really the
criminals actually helped that right i
love how she's like you have barely any
gun laws i'm like
what are you talking about yeah she
didn't know anything about texas but she
doesn't know anything about a whole lot
yeah so no this is an issue again why
could it could not be less relevant if
someone owned a firearm
illegally and the message that they want
to put out there is
so cops right now are really afraid to
do their job uh
they're they're they're they're nervous
they're apprehensive
because there are more law-abiding
concealed carry permits your floor
what hold on a second yeah does anyone
really believe this this is what i
wonder this is why i don't often talk
about msnbc you can comment
do you know anybody who actually
believes that police feel hamstrung
because more law-abiding citizens carry
firearms who by the way people who have
firearm permits
are less likely to commit any crime
than even police officers and i know
you'll say well now but anyone can carry
well again
carrying a firearm does come with
stipulations you can't drink as much
there are certain areas where you cannot
be
you obviously can't have committed
violent crimes or felon this is
something where
you're not going to take that risk
because there's a harsher harsher
penalty
if you are not allowed to carry that
firearm
but that's the reason the cops can't do
their job right now well stephen we need
more
you know strict gun laws you know like i
don't know let me think chicago because
then maybe our shootings will go down
right because they have really strict
gun laws and nothing goes wrong
they never bring those up no new
jersey's the number one state to live
no that's what hurts the south side of
chicago almost no guns
almost none everything that guy just
says [ __ ]
okay and by the way msnbc totally
contradicted themselves later when
people are no longer paying attention
and
something something minor here you go
doug cantor died and was killed this
weekend in austin because
two people had guns they shouldn't have
had
yes that's a whole point yes
correct they didn't go they didn't go
purchase it at a gun
show right next to the bass pro that guy
sounded like jeffrey tubin at a meeting
well the soft sound of tapping played in
the background
um all right so look again this is just
one of those things where this this
crime is absolutely unreal right now
we're going to get to putin in a second
but first
actually um we have a new sponsor really
excited about this yeah yeah
built bar um and i'll explain this now
first let me be really clear
i'm not really a big supplement guy and
i cannot make any claims of course you
can't make any claims right and i
wouldn't have bill parker look eating a
protein bar is not going to make you
it's not going to make you superhuman
you're going to be the hulk that being
said
quarterback garrett remembers when i
broke my femur yeah i stabbed my knee
horrible
yeah um and i can't make any claims but
i did afterward eat a build bar and i
think
i think it might have helped
my ankle just let me pull yeah
i guess we'll use one of the first takes
[Music]
[Music]
maybe
draw your own conclusions no i make no
claims
i leave that to you the people so
uh look this is actually something the
reason i've been eating built bars for a
while
i'm not big on supplements it's just a
dessert replacement it's great i had
their own
unbelievable like they're salted caramel
it just tastes like a box of chocolates
yeah and they're double chocolate just
take i don't know if i'm allowed to say
it just tastes like a three musketeers
so i don't you don't need to eat protein
bars you don't need to eat supplements
but if you're just trying to cut back on
some sweets this is the only thing
replacement had that even comes close to
actually replacing a candy bar
and it's high in protein has fiber in
there low in carbs if you use the promo
code crowder15
at billboard.com you get 15 off oh
crowder 15. so
you don't need them but it tastes
delicious
and i eat them that rhymed they really
are good yeah you gave me one yesterday
and i
really enjoyed it by the way you don't
need a discount if you just steal them
at a walgreens stop yes
that's true yeah also free at walgreens
why the 950 by the way what's what was
the secret to that number
to what that was like 950 that's the
line
i don't know what is 949 i have no idea
but
by the way take 100 of them right yeah
putin right now is total power move
just so people know total power move
he's just making people wait
oh yeah by the way do you want to have a
joint press conference no no
no no he probably said yes and he's
standing him up like never been kissed
oh right
just biden showing up by himself waiting
for a limo and he's throwing eggs
hey vp standing on the 18th green
getting his pants wet from the
sprinklers
tp is motorcade
it's the ninth hole at midnight it's a
secret of us kgb
yeah all right so look this is one thing
i want to talk about too right now um
before i get to anything do you want to
know how you know
california is a really crappy state
they've had to bail out
weed yeah big weed gotta bail out think
about it
it gets you high right it's cool to
people
it's it's it's now legal it's habit
forming it practically sells itself
it's incredibly profitable too from what
i've heard heard it doesn't matter
doesn't matter so before i get to that
today is tupac's birthday
like his death birthday oh yeah birthday
um and to celebrate here's
vice president mcauliffe who cares
kamala harris
reflecting on her days of listening to
tupac and doing drugs oh now i remember
this clip
uh i think it was she talked about
before tupac could have been a thing and
this is before by the way she
purposefully
imprisoned uh non-violent drug offenders
what does carmela harris listen to
what were you listening to when you was
high what was wrong
with you let me get it let me be fake
for a second
uh tupac for sure what's your favorite
hip-hop artist now what's your favorite
art you know i really love
it's cardi b oh that's charlotte maine
the god show
i don't call him that yes charlemagne
charlemagne yeah
i call him [ __ ] bag yeah well that's i
mean no he's like
charlemagne the god self-declared really
lowercase yeah i'm probably not gonna i
believe it's t-h-a
t-h-a the god yeah oh by the way it's
not even usually when you change the
spelling
it's to either make it shorter to say or
easier to write
you just changed it to another vowel
what about wu-tang
what about wu-tang well do you go with
all their names well no i just say wu
tang
all right hold on a second we have we
have uh we have i was about to say we
have president putin it looks like he's
about to do a power point
right now uh um president i guess
where's this vitamin
you think i bring androgynous trends to
sign for me
people don't need sign you look in my
eyes
he's in a stall in the middle of an
enemy's room with a neck taped with
piano wire
all right let's see do they have a
translator the arctic and so on and so
forth your questions please
that was his view
let social know that we're live
streaming this right now we'll go back
to good evening
perhaps you could tell us which
topics you discussed in greater detail
particularly the ukrainian
issue did you talk about the donbass did
you talk about
the accession of ukraine to nato
and what about the expected return of
the
two ambassadors to their posts
what uh decisions were made
more local you find yourself in cell
next to [ __ ] riot right
shut it oh here's an idea i kill you
what is her name okay answer ambassadors
we agreed
should return to their posts
and take up their functions
it's a technical question as to exactly
when that will happen
tomorrow day after tomorrow or whatever
and the consultations will begin on a
whole raft of diplomatic issues
as has already been said accumulated
over time
and we believe that the american side is
determined to look at solutions as far
as ukraine is concerned
this we certainly did touch upon it i
can't say in a very detailed way but
uh president biden agrees that
at the basis of any kind of solution to
the problems in ukraine
uh lie the minsk agreements
as far as do you notice
nato
i don't think there's anything to
discuss
by the way lily just said that there's a
teleprompter oh really
yeah is that for putin or is that for
buddy
do we know if putin's on teleprompter no
but apparently he
did bring uh press secretary and biden
nobody correspondent don't bring a press
secretary to a ruski fight
what zip guns
you don't bring us you'll bring a chain
to a pool party
what will russia and the us
resume negotiations on the whole
question of strategic security and
disarmament and particularly with regard
to start
three are you going to have
discussions as to further prolongation
thank you i'm not sure the
us and the russian federation have a
particular responsibility for strategic
stability in the world in as much as we
are the two biggest um nuclear powers
uh in terms of the quantity of warheads
and
nuclear weapons and also in terms of the
quality
that's a flex of modern nuclear
weaponry we realized that double flex
i think it's absolutely obvious on
quantity and technological capabilities
by the way i'm pretty sure
responsibility to
prolong the start three negotiations for
five
years
and of course the whole question notice
he didn't cough into his elbow after
that
we agreed that he caught into his
friend borderline smeared on the mic
into agency take it
between them i give it to you you take
it out
give it to you you like it and
uh you like women you like knives
delegates on the uh mission are going to
talk about the further details of that
in due course do you notice too how the
reporters it's not like the gaggle that
you saw it yeah
well really they only did it with
president donald trump but those
reporters are terrified
first of all could you characterize the
dynamic between
yourself and everybody okay or was it
friendly
and secondly throughout these
conversations did you commit
to ceasing carrying out cyber attacks on
the united states did you commit
to stopping that guy's gonna die you
created security
and did you commit to stop cracking down
on the opposite what will happen to you
will make clinton body count look like
child's play i'm so sad to hear about
your suicide tomorrow sir
going to paint my bedroom with your
brains as far as that is concerned i
don't think there was any kind of
hostility on the contrary
our meeting was obviously
a fundamental one many of our joint
positions
are divergent but nevertheless i think
that both sides
manifested um determination to
try and understand each other and try
and converge our positions
and i think it was very constructive as
far as
yeah cyber security is concerned we
agreed
that we would begin consultations on
that issue
oh my gosh come on dude i believe that's
extraordinary important
and obviously both sides have to assume
certain
obligations there i'd like to inform you
that
i think it's common knowledge
perhaps not to the public at large but
the american administration i don't want
to actually
say which body it is
but american sources say that
the majority of cyber attacks in the
world
uh are in fact
on the cyberspace in the us and then the
second
um place is canada and the third is uk
that right there was a challenge on that
list that right there was a challenge
either what he just said was true or
it needs to be refuted by a president
with balls
when he just said i won't say which body
but maybe public does not know this
in other words this is not public
information and it can't be verified
because it's likely not true but most
no cyber terrorism is from us of a
your ball yeah now if i were joe
if they were if it were donald trump
right now oh yeah he'd be changing the
good thing is he wasn't on prompter he'd
be changing his speech
yeah as we speak yeah if nothing else
does anyone want to argue with the fact
that donald trump
took things too personally yeah and a
challenge like that
yeah that's why putin was very
complimentary of donald trump
because he understood that it just
doesn't pay to piss him off
well it's all part of negotiations like
putin basically walked out and said
i gave him card to geek squad said call
for help
yes when asked about security i was like
what do you what do you guys think
you talked about nothing you're not
gonna do anything then i gave him uh
how you say in america um swirly
he said he prefers nogis but i gave him
swirlies
and uh for father's day colombian
necktie
yes yes what huh
racist tradition no all right let's hear
what he has to say that was a challenge
right there and it'll be interesting to
see if
former vice president joe biden steps up
to it yeah in general and in particular
for the us and to the same extent for
russia
for example we know about cyber attacks
on the pipeline company in the us
and we know that the company had to pay
out five million
i got half well you know can i say one
thing really quickly too
do you know why um this administration
is in such a position of weakness
with russia when we're talking about
cyber attacks
because they tried to make it the witch
hunt for so long
this administration needs to prove that
boogeyman true right
in other words they need to make russia
out to be these cyber hacking geniuses
that they that they attempted to for
four years in order to try and undermine
the trump presidency again keep in mind
oh yeah yeah no association at all with
donald trump right
so right now russia what they what putin
just needs to do is say
look they've made many accusations
non-stop
hearings investigations i am saying
pipeline usa hackers you say russian
heck
prove it oh that's right you can't
that's what's happening right now yeah
he's holding some cards
that he didn't hold against donald trump
well and biden's approaching him from
the stance of we want to be friends with
the world again and it doesn't matter if
it's in our best interest or not and so
all of the world is saying oh
okay so you're you're reversing the
policy at the worst you should have just
gone
donald trump said a few things that i
didn't like but we're going to continue
to be tough on people that do things
wrong in the international it's so
disingenuous we want to be friends
with the uh nation who we accuse of
cyber hacking
and destroying our democracy and rigging
our elections we want to be friends with
that country russia right
water under the bridge there's no way to
be strong in that position there is
zero chance you don't know where they
line up keep in mind remember barack
obama when he was debating mitt romney
said
the 1980's called it won't bring russian
policy back then russia decided yeah you
know what crimea
okay that sounds like fun ukraine great
isis let's create it they did all this
under barack obama's watch then all of a
sudden because they needed a boogeyman
to try and say donald trump was remember
they questioned the legitimacy of the
election in 2016.
people don't remember that amy klobuchar
elizabeth warren they had commissions
jimmy carter
you can go through all of it and they
blamed it on russia
made a lot of accusations and we know
that several quite a few of them were
false now i'm not saying
that there weren't russian hackers of
course not but what i am saying is now
putin has the cards to say well this is
what we can prove as far as american
hackers
you prove what you you prove what you
say again it's just
it's someone who talks a lot former vice
president joe biden
who's insulting who's confrontational
but from a position
of weakness substantively that's the
worst
posturing you can take as a world leader
yeah be silent and strong or talk a
bunch of [ __ ]
and be strong the only option that is
unacceptable
is to talk a bunch of crap like calling
someone a killer and accusing them of
hijacking your elections
and then saying but maybe we can like be
friends
yeah you can't do it no and this man
does you think a former kgb
officer is going to respect that no you
know the reason he looks bored because
in his downtime he's feeding dissidents
to bears
stephen like this guy is killing people
and imprisoning people who disagree with
them
he's like i gotta give a press
conference and answer questions this
isn't normal
maybe it's not known to american public
but of course in russia you make
rock band we send you to bear jail
where's the church follow-up yes
uh trent with the bbc what is perhaps
bad jail interesting you should ask we
take
people you know hooligans punk rockers
and we put them
in room with bears if they can fight off
bear
they get to go free there are a few but
most time we just add more bears
[Laughter]
ah eventually it's a volume game you
understand
pump up the volume christian slate if
you can make it past
949 bears it's not a crime ah
jeez come on man
all right let's see what he has to say
then we'll continue on with it honestly
this is
he just flexed on nukes yeah yeah and he
just flexed on saying actually
i know you are but what am i i am rubber
you are glue saying no you guys are the
cyber threats you guys are the cyber
terrorists that's not good that's not
good and unless biden comes out
forcefully and i know people will say
donald trump was to yeah but donald
donald trump didn't have
to come out forcefully because putin
didn't accuse donald trump's
administration
of spying on russia right you know you
should
look at what the us is doing not the
russian oh
there we go very interesting as far as
our non-systematic or non-standard
um opposition is concerned and the
gentleman you quoted
first of all this man knew that he was
uh breaking the law of russia
i assume sorry he is somebody who has
been
twice convicted and he consciously
ign ignored the requirements of the law
the gentleman in question went abroad
for treatment
his registration was not asked for
as soon as he got to the hospital he
showed his
videos on the internet but he
ignored the demands of the laws
and knowing about that he came back to
russia and
so i take view that he wanted
consciously to break the law he did
exactly what he wanted to do
so what kind of discussion are we having
what can we talk about there as far as
unofficial positions no i will say it's
concerning i think the people in russia
understand the five-figure discount for
949 dollars
not saying he's right in this situation
but there is a mindset of it
he knew he was break he knew there was
law he broke it
knowing there was law and so now we're
in for his law yes
his fingers are not my necklace yeah
spectators these are not poker shells
these were
shrunken fingers like little head yes
but
the fingers on my yes i wear on vacation
i come back with beads in my hair
yes appropriation bernie knows
he bought two yes hey isn't it ironic
that
your senator who run for president honey
moon
here in russia and now russia
is homie moon and your president
you can't get away from me
all right look we don't need to go they
can let us know what happens yeah um
do we want to continue with the with the
weed segment or should we go to charles
barkley because
the show is now running late uh dude
barkley because i don't want to skip
through weed you've got a pretty good
part yeah all right i'll go through look
uh long story short california's banning
weed and
the arguments that you guys uh sorry not
banning they're bailing out weed but
they are all of these states are banning
cbd delta th delta delta eight thc
which is legal in a state like texas
where wheat is not legal because they
want to lock out competition so the idea
that if you end uh
if you legalize all drugs you'll end the
drug war not true and the idea that uh
well you know what no one should go to
prison or be arrested or be a criminal
for smoking a joint well i agree with
you but now in states like colorado
you're a criminal
if you uh smoke a delta thc8 joint so
look it's big business just admit it and
the drug cartels are making more than
ever to the point that california has to
bail out weed but we'll talk about that
more tomorrow because
charles barkley is a lot of fun he has
some really good points lately
yes he does oh and by the way if you're
watching this right now hit the share
button
sharing is caring oh um i'm trying to
remember here didn't want the rainbow
where do we talk about uh i guess well
uno this is something that we should
probably talk about oh yeah we don't
need to skip that yeah when you share
that by the way you can just hit twitter
or facebook uno
is having a everyone's getting on the
pride yeah yes
because the proud people are feeling
proud very proud sure there are there
are a lot of reasons to be proud
of stuff to be yes in america yes
freedom corporations
people who died for no president no
veterans do you get a day
do you wear do you wear a leather choker
and have sex with men on floats at
folsom
yep then you get a day you get a
month and to appropriate the rainbow
someone tell a pot of gold because their
chocolates won't like it
is that a canadian thing pot of gold
chocolates we had keebler oh so
oh okay it was a leprechaun behold the
pot of gold
no no canadians have to let me know pot
of gold was our thing you guys have
russell stover
well we also had three leprechauns oh we
did
we didn't leave with keebler we had
lucky charms as well and then yeah
well he was so low he was so low did
skittles change
taste the rainbow the rainbow
uh so there's now there's pride uno
because everywhere
everything has to be sexualized yeah uh
and
that being said i would say don't knock
until you try it because uh
we we got a deck and it's it was a good
time did i hear all that right
oh skip your turn skip your turn
suck all right skip your turn
suck and switch to rainbow
what are you more of a bridge guy
[Music]
i don't know what the crossover age is
to when you become a bridge person
okay look dave wake up i don't care if
you got bored about putin here wake up
he's not paid by the hour here what um i
don't know what the ih crossover is for
bridge
i think it's the same as walmart greeter
it has to be
yeah it's got to be old people but
literally when do you wake up one day
and just look i was wrong about bridge
all these years that seems to be what
happens
it seems there's a crossover if you're
above 80 you know the intricacies of
bridge yeah i wouldn't even know what
kind of a deck do you need for bridge
well i think
when you don't have bridge you just drop
your grandparents off at the casino so
they can get rid of the last pennies
they have yes
that they're not just playing bridge now
my nana would play bridge but she hated
every
she hated old people it was always funny
she's just talking about how he's like
yeah they're gross all they do is
complain
like you're one of them my grandfather
who by the way was mayor of bloomfield
township was a bombardier in world war
ii a professor built two homes with his
bare hands which i'm sure we could like
learn to do with the kid house but yeah
go on the second
floor and it's he he
uh didn't he got dementia when he got
older i don't know if his dementia is
alzheimer's
can you have a combo of both because
they would use the term sort of
interchangeable spider dust okay
oh well and then
he would go to a local casino and use a
slot the penny slots and i swear to you
four times in a row first penny he got
like 50 bucks or a hundred bucks
to the point where in his demented old
mind
he just thought it was the hundred
dollar machine yeah
i put a penny in and then i get more
and that's what happened then one time
he didn't he didn't get what he wanted
she started throwing his change the
casino
no no it's supposed to give me 50s
oh geez i can't wait
it's gonna be good well look you
transition to whatever game you can when
the game includes uh doing some of the
things that were muted or bleeped
there yeah i will play bridge as opposed
to gay uno can i say one more thing no
you won't
my father-in-law you met my
father-in-law by the way father
he is hysterical he has one of the
driest sense of humors and he has the
super low baritone boys
and they used to go to the casino it was
like every thursday and every tuesday
and thursday right because at this point
it was like seniors go free penny slots
whatever so at that point you know my
grandma she's 97 now
yeah she would take him there and he
would have fun and that one time when he
freaks out my father-in-law
are there and he goes and goes no oh no
it's not the
100 i'm never coming here again my final
audience says
want to bet i don't know
lost it
all right so charles barkley yeah is now
being canceled before we go to a mug
club we'll be taking your chats by the
way live with credit.com and talking
about uh joe lewis here doug
argentino a story yesterday oh i feared
for my life
um charles barkley's being canceled for
you did you know about this because your
sports got his running gag of
big old women from san antonio i don't
watch a whole lot of charles barkley but
i've heard of that i've seen his golf
swing too and that's a sight to behold
is it not good uh we can probably pull
that him and bread garrett were playing
together brad's also a
horrible horrible golfer and title is
called and said they would give him ten
thousand dollars to their charity to
take off their pets
and it's not just that charles i think
it was charles barkley i'm 99 sure
it's not just he's he was bad at the
time his golf swing looked like the
person who was swinging the club had
never played a sport in his life
right and you're talking about one of
the best basketball players in history
i'm sure he's probably self-deprecating
about it though oh yeah
we might actually have hilarious about
do we
charles barkley's golf god
it's worse than that they're looking
like followers through there
go in the hole you knucklehead no no so
that even though at the end of every
golf swing even if it's on tv
it's him swearing that's part of his
golf swing
i i gotta say i'm not there's already
like pauses and like stops and stuff
like oh do you have another one all
right let's
see the other one let
but you know i guarantee you i probably
couldn't do better all right we
we understand that his golf swing is
subpar
i'm going to actually tell you you are a
better golfer than charles sparkles yes
i have no
i don't know just kidding when you pause
halfway through your swing and do like
that and then
and then get shocked that you didn't hit
a great shot like it's like all right
bend your knees a little bit
and make sure to keep your feet and head
down to swing through he's like so none
of that
exactly those are what not to do this is
a pro
charles barkley segment guys i love it
i love charles he's hilarious i mean
this side of love i love brad garrett
watching them play
golf together one of my favorite things
then alice cooper comes in and smokes
them all and he's not even crazy oh yeah
he's really all right so
uh he's actually now someone he's people
been trying to cancel him
right again making fun of the big women
from san antonio it's one of the longest
running jokes in sports just for the oh
yeah he's been
and he just he just does he has a thing
with the spurs with san antonio so
anyway there was an article
written by a lady named madeleine
mendoza uh who wrote barkley's
thatched shaming stick has been going on
for years
yes his studio banter has involved
bashing an entire city of women
mostly to get a reaction that's
hilarious like you
barkley will use any opportunity to
disparage local
ladies that's not true only if the
ladies are local to san antonio
here is his response i love to the
cancel
mob when asked this is why you don't
apologize if you crack a joke the wrong
way
they're like oh no no no no you crossed
the line i mean they won't even let me
talk about san antonio anymore
you know you know what i'm always
talking about them big old women down in
san antonio
they're like charles we got one lady
wrote an article
i'm like first of all i didn't call
anybody
personally fat in san antonio i was just
joking around and well this one lady
wrote this article i'm like so y'all
gonna let one lady
we've been having fun with this for
probably 10-15 years
and when we go to san antonio the people
are having a blast with it
i mean the people in san antonio they
had t-shirts made up
now i mean i don't have to go back there
in the morning the team sucks
i'm trying to hang on for another couple
years till i'm 60
and then they can kiss my ass because i
oh i love it just for context here's a
short compilation very short because you
can watch them that are like 50 minutes
long
of uh his ongoing joke uh with
the women from san antone they're out of
the gates eight and one time for
never stop never settle presented by
hennessy
i bet you couldn't do that to them big
ass women in san antonio
why do you like san antonio oh man i
look skinny down there
that san antonio goes and then skimpy
down in san antonio
[Laughter]
national treasure people are going to
take this offensively
the white guy with the bow tie was fired
immediately yes
american exercises like stop saying her
name stuck saying no
and by the way he's not even i
understand why maybe some women might be
upset because the truth is it's houston
houston have the they have
yeah they are partly different but it's
a reoccurring trash talk in sports
that's right
of course absolutely that's how it goes
and this is why women shouldn't sound
off
shouldn't give their opinion on men's
sports
if you don't like it go watch the wnba
but you
don't and have you been somebody sodium
they're disgusting
i'm kidding actually san antonio are
getting tend to be more
houston no yeah no no everybody knows a
lot of
women in texas are beautiful yeah well
they can um
aren't my charles
has always been funny he's always been
funny always yes
here's my ques okay do people watch so i
have a question about this first off
i know i'm not gonna ask you one of the
like one of those you know like philip
defranco's like what are you doing soon
enough
i'm not going to ask you if you think
that women in san antonio are fat
because the answer is yes but i want to
ask you
if just specifically women women out
there we have a lot of women who watch
show
who are overweight if you happen to be
from san antonio so much the better
i want you to let me know comment below
uh
if you were offended as a fat woman
you may be beautiful but but you
probably die
so um and by the way charles barkley's
also the guy that running down the court
is yelling at the ref i know he's
michael jordan
i know but he does commit fouls yeah
everyone he's got a lot of sense of
humor about these he's also had a weight
problem himself
yeah he was huge he goes they make me
look thin that was basically him saying
i'm really big
so much deprecation look this is just
deprecation he's
always been that perfect line too where
he never seems to step over it until now
when they claim that he is right
but he always had that right amount of
trash talking where you could keep a
camera on
right no the line moved charles barkley
hasn't changed that's what i mean
completely yeah i know
the line moved because they had to fit
all the women from san antonio
they had to make the courts smaller to
get them to watch out loud they just
move one
cankle forward they're guilty of icing i
don't know
i don't know the basketball rules uh but
i understand why someone could be
offended so uh actually it's time um
for us to give recognition to our
honorary san antonio resident of the
month
this is a public service announcement
big girl summer has officially begun
and big girls we have abs
look at that look at that i know you see
it
fabs honey stay sick stay mad hoe
where my big girl's at
is that is that
at what point does it be what point is
it again with the youtube guidelines is
it an
immutable characteristic um versus you
just turned the volume
up i just lost all hope
i mean metric volume well look if big
girl summer has started i'll just be
inside
yeah i'll stay inside it sounds like oh
davey's gonna be going to the pool
[Laughter]
sounds great i like me morbid i just uh
look please look and you know look
uh yep watch it who makes a bikini like
that i don't know man even to
manufacture your life is big and tall
what do you think you think this is
gross
big enough no i think the only way you
get those off the shelf is when there's
a war effort and parachute makers yeah
that's true
yeah why
it's like you killed a damn cheetah look
i don't know uh
it's just an unfortunate it's unf
uh okay so here's a song too can you
my aunt who's a nurse taught she is a
nurse and yeah
because of the bigger woman they come in
with yeast and yeah they get used to
under the fold yeah under the fold
they got themselves some muffins they
got them
they could do some bacon over there um i
just i didn't expect to i
i seriously i threw up in my mouth a
little and that's not here's the point
it's not an immutable characteristic
this is the issue right now with when
you're talking about fat pride
uh and i i don't know the lady who wrote
the article uh against charles barkley
yeah
but i'll make a bat
that's a safe bet at the very least
she's not happy with herself
for similar reasons i bet you there's a
lot of backspacing from
palming the keypad yeah yes just for
them big old
so many letters i accidentally hit four
again
yeah she set her emergency code on her
phone for nine on one to just
mash
it's just like for first off i just
i mean i just it's just you should be
allowed to make fun of people in san
antonio
and i should be allowed to make fun of
someone who is declaring their own abs
to be
fab you know how many fat people are in
detroit in the midwest
where i'm from there's fat people
everywhere it's america
we have lots i don't know if you know
this we've spread them out tons of us
everything this is the issue here
everything bad is good everything
perverse is something that everyone
needs to tolerate and accept and i'm not
getting into anything specific here
but okay you know what let me get
specific 949
if you steal it that's fine it's justice
right
if you prosecute if you defend your own
property
you're wrong well i don't know we'll
base it on race obesity
beautiful brave they will remove you
from certain social media platforms
for suggesting the opposite and then
accuse you of being anti-science
while they then next election cycle
accuse you of being in the pocket
of big pharma as they currently cut
advertisements for vaccines that create
billions of dollars in revenue for two
companies in this country
everything i'm not i'm not anti-vaccine
at all i'm just pointing out the
hypocrisy
here when people try and say big pharma
really you just did a commercial for
moderate when people say you know what
let's not shame people okay i'm all for
i'm all for not shaming other people at
the same time i'm all for
people having shame
that's a good point now motivator now
exactly shame should be internal
right corrosive to your own soul not
others that's how it works
it's a good thing for you to feel shame
now you shouldn't be
shamed but you should have shame in
behavior that is shameful most notably
when people say well that's subjective
okay
so let's go with the scientific view
here
shameful behavior is something that is
objectively scientifically harmful
would it be appropriate to probably feel
shameful if you currently engage in that
behavior let's say heroin
addiction there you go yeah encouraging
other people to do
heroin i don't know if you're hunter
parmesan whatever you care
good breed whatever it is but the point
is
you should feel shameful not because
someone is shaming you
but hopefully your doctor and those in
the medical establishment say
actually you're at significantly higher
risk for diabetes stroke
cardio complications cardiovascular
complications and by the way
while we're out here praising fat pride
and saying that you can't comment on an
immutable characteristic which
i'm not sure how immutable uh calories
in versus calories out
is but while we're saying you can't
actually point out immutable
characteristics while these people
promote said non-immutable
characteristics to young children and we
have an obesity epidemic hey
what's the one thing you could change
right now in relation to covid
the one thing that you could change that
not a single scientist
not a single microbiologist virologist
immunologist epidemiologist would
disagree with
lose some weight lose some weight get
your bmi lower
you do that you increase your chances of
having fewer coveted complications
exponentially there is no refuting it
but objectively we can't say
hey hey maybe fat pride isn't so
beautiful on a ventilator i don't know
all right look
we have more to talk about that we can't
talk about here on the youtubes
uh you can well rumble if you're there
at the rumble uh rumble place you can
smash that rumble button because we are
available on rumble at the same time as
youtube and it's a live show monday
through thursday tomorrow cultural
appropriation month
yeah grease i have to shave a sweater
vest
into my chest youtube piss off
you